a little faster as our car tester
anticipates we tells us every three
years Volvo holds the Ocean Race a
spectacular sailing regatta
circumnavigating the globe this October
is the next start Volvo is marking the
occasion by launching a special Ocean
Race Edition for various existing Volvo
models the design takes up the motifs of
wind waves and water today we'll look at
the xc60 in the Ocean Race design so how
does a maritime exterior fit a SUV
designed for rough ground
the xc60 may not be as sleek as a
sailboat but both are fairly robust on
the nine stages of the thirty-nine
thousand mile gotta the six sealing
teams dock in 12 cities between these
destinations why some of the world's
most demanding seas the aquatic
equivalent of off-road terrain
the ocean reefs designed for cars builds
on Volvo's most basic equipment package
kinetic refining it with its own touches
like orange seams on the foot mats and
leather seats
the special edition cost an additional
3,200 euros but it means added comfort
like heated seats and an infotainment
system the central console is subtly
decorated with the names of the cities
that the sailing teams head for on the
9-month Ocean Race
the rear luggage cover not only screens
baggage from view it also presents the
regatta route on a map of the world by
the way the race ends in Volvo's
hometown Gert de Bourg in June 2015
one thing the xc60 has in common with a
sailboat is plenty of room for
provisions
so the xc60 can set up well prepared for
a long voyage
women even says that along with all the
little details of the ocean race design
interior the xc60 s panoramic glass roof
can be open to let in a bit of sea
breeze or mountain breeze for that
matter
the most conspicuous aspect of the
exterior is this exclusive shade of blue
silver mother a pair and metallic black
are also available these light metal
wheel rims are also available
exclusively with the Ocean Race design
the engine has power to 350 Newton
meters of torque and Shore speed and
headwind or tailwind
come on eNOS now wants to see whether
her ocean race xc60 test car lives up to
the race part it has 85 engine with 180
kilowatts the transmission is at eight
gear automatic it shifts so promptly
that you always have optimal power the
eighth gear automatic can be put into S
mode so the gears shift even more
quickly and respond even more directly
to the gas pedal gear shift paddles on
the steering wheel enable the driver to
shift manually on blacktop
the xc60 launches from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour and 7.2 seconds the
cars top speed is 210 kilometers an hour
and it consumes only 6.7 liters of fuel
per 100 kilometers of course it helps of
a good tailwind in your sails
a car tester eNOS says the interplay of
all the little design details gives the
Ocean Race edition its special charm she
especially likes the blue color which
takes up the ocean motif perfectly along
with the world map on the luggage
covered for a whiff of adventure